place à l'invité politique je reçois ce
soir marielle de sarnez vice présidente
du modem chef de file du parti pour les
régionales en île de france et
eurodéputé bonsoir marielle de sarnez
cerner une réaction en tant
qu'eurodéputé à ce qu'on a appris
aujourd'hui apparemment les services
secrets allemands qui écoute la france à
l'elysée au quai d'orsay qui écoutent
aussi airbus et eurocopter
s'il est avéré c'est très très grave il
écoute la france à la demande de la nsa
les etats-unis demandent des états unis
alors on a déjà eu le scandale de la nsa
vous souvenez angela merkel avait même
été écoutés sur ce portable est elle
avait dit on n'écoute pas ses amis alors
si on peut imaginer si tout ça est vrai
que les abeilles qui on demandait aux
services secrets allemands d'écouter la
france les responsables français et des
responsables industriels par exemple
comme airbus ou un stade immense
scandale il ya quelque chose qui ne
marche pas correctement alors ya une
enquête en cours ou moules ce tag mais
il va falloir que l'allemagne nous
disent très très vite ce qu'il en a été
et ce qu'il en est pour l'instant n'y a
pas de réaction de la france en tout cas
on n'a pas entendu qui que ce soit
haussé la voix vous le regrettez je
pense qu'ils attendent les résultats de
cette enquête il ya une enquête en cours
donc moi je veux bien qu'on dise qu'on
attend mais en tous les cas si jamais
c'est avéré c'est extrêmement grave
déjà quand les américains écoutent le
monde entier la planète entière
c'est grave alors en plus quand on a des
alliés européens qui écoutent leurs
propres alliés leurs propres amis et qui
plus est avec des intérêts industriels
derrière ça pose beaucoup de questions
ça pose notamment en particulier la
question et services secrets est ce que
les services secrets font ça au führer
de leur propre chef entre services
secrets américains et services secrets
allemands ou sur ordre de la joie et ce
qu'ils font ça sur mandat alors les deux
sondes ave un mandat politique
évidemment ce serait grave c'est sans
mandat sans mandat ce serait très très
grave aussi et c'est toute la question
de voilà les smiths secret c'est
important et en même temps ils doivent
pas agir en dehors de la légalité
on vous dit c'est très très grave c'est
à dire si c'est avéré qu'est ce qu'il
faudrait faire
enfin si c'est avéré j'attends
évidemment il y aura des explications de
l'allemagne en phase i s'est avérée si
tout cela est exact
ça remet en cause beaucoup de choses y
compris même pour l'allemagne puisque
visiblement dirigeants allemands n'ont
pas l'air d'être au courant de ce qui
s'est passé vous soient vos informations
ben c'est ce qui se dit c'est ce qui
s'est dit aujourd'hui qu'il n'avait pas
l'air d'être tout à fait quoi alors je
vous dis à cette enquête en cours au
bundestag
je pense qu'on va savoir en tous les cas
ce qui s'est passé il alors il le faut
il faut clarifier la position to stay de
rendre de plus en plus possible
effectivement par les capacités des
côtes d'oran éloignement énorme des lois
qui viennent d'ailleurs valider tout
cela ça va être le cas en france avec la
loi renseignement si vous étiez députés
en france de la vôtre y est je pense
qu'il faut faire attention c'est à dire
que oui bien sûr il faut faire tout ce
qu'on peut mais en même temps quand on
va pour écouter une personne en écouter
sans ou en écoute 500 on l'écoutait 5000
il ya une proportionnalité qui doit être
respecté et deuxièmement je pense qu'il
faut que le juge intervienne que tout ça
se fasse dans le cadre d'un état de
droit et pas en dehors de l'état de
droit dont je poserai des amendements
qui irait exactement dans ce sens en
l'état vous ne le voteriez pas si je
comprends bien là je pense qu'il faut
une protection
il faut que l'état de droit s'applique
et une protection des libertés
individuelles et en l'état elle ne
s'applique pas faut que je vous dis moi
je déposerai des monde ment donc on va
voir comment ça va à ressortir du débat
à l'assemblée
mais je pense que au départ c'était
insuffisant
effectivement hier manuel valls annoncé
la création d'une structure d'accueil
pour les jeunes djihadistes qui serait
de retour qui en feraient la demande et
qu'ils ne seraient pas poursuivis
judiciairement est ce que cette
angélique ou pragmatique
qu'est ce que vous en pensez il ya des
pays européens qui l'ont fait c'est à
dire qu'il ya des pays européens
notamment des pays scandinaves qui se
sont rendus compte qu'il ya des gens qui
sont partis là bas en syrie qui
voulaient entre guillemets fait le jihad
ou petits poulets s'engager là bas
certains rester et serdar venu en disant
s'est trompé de chemin on veut se
réinsérer donc il ya comme ça des
structures qui existent dans les pays
scandinaves si si cet état d'esprit de
se dire il y en a un sur cinq en tout
ils sont rentrés revient aux polices et
noir se sont trompés et on peut essayer
de les rattraper
eh bien oui bien sûr pour que ça
fonctionne mais pas dans l'isthme et pas
de naïveté
donc il vaut mieux ne pas se tromper
mais ça existe et je trouve que c'est
mieux que ça glisse parce que si ça
n'existe pas celui qui s'est trompé
qu'est-ce qui fait
as tu es là bas bon il faut qu'il puisse
revenir et qu'on puisse éventuellement
qu'ils puissent être réinsérés
éventuellement on va parler de politique
intérieure si vous le voulez bien des
régionales vous êtes chef de file du
modem en ile-de-france mais vous avez
créé la surprise mardi en déclarant je
suis p cressot compatible compatible
avec valérie pécresse là la chef de file
de l'ump ça veut dire quoi
tel un peu vite j'ai dit oh j'ai dit on
à des approches qui peuvent être
compatibles
voilà cela veut dire quoi cela remet ça
veut dire que par exemple on veut toutes
les deux le changement la région ile de
france on pense toutes les deux un jeune
de france est une très grande région on
y est là aujourd'hui à paris ces 20%
population c'est 30 % du pib de la
france
moi je trouve que cette région ben ça va
pas ça veut dire quoi c'est trop tôt
pour dire quoi boucler la réforme allait
au bout ça veut dire une statue n'est en
fait qu'une nice à lyon qu'on pourra
peut-être le moment venu parce que moi
je pour l'instant je suis en précampagne
nous sommes avec yann wehrling qui est
chef de file avec moi nous sommes tous
les deux en pré campagne jusque l'été à
l'été on définira nos stratégies dans
chacune des régions de france et moi
j'ai dit que ben pourquoi pas on va voir
on va travailler on va regarder les
choses on va porter d'abord pendant ces
trois quatre mois
l'identité du centre les attentes du
centre les aspirations des électeurs du
centre déjà chanté à la région quant à
la région de l'île de france
et puis oui je suis pas fermé à l'idée
de rassemblement large parce que je
crois qu'il faut pas il faut pas
seulement gagner mais faudra pouvoir
gouverner différemment cette région et
quand je dis vous voulez différemment
cette région moi je crois qu'il faudra
des ruptures savez c'est très compliqué
aujourd'hui de voir avec le millefeuille
qui existe qui fait quoi
à quoi sert exactement l'argent comment
elle peut vraiment contribuer au
développement économique à
l'apprentissage à des transports qui
soit franchement plus correct pour les
franciliens
on a un gros boulot à faire et je pense
que le faire dans le cadre de
rassemblement large ça peut être une
bonne chose
la question que
beaucoup de gens se posent j'imagine
c'est ici l'oedème et et l'ump peuvent
s'entendre et s'allier dans une région
comme vous le dites aussi importante et
aussi grande que l'île de france alors
pourquoi ne pourrait-elle pas le faire
dans les autres régions est une manière
générale au niveau national c est ce que
dit françois bayrou marielle de sarnez
aussi vous savez on est à peu près
calais françois bayrou et moi en tournée
et la rioja l'auvergne et le centre for
cette côte d'azur il a une valeur de 18
ans je viens de vous dire on verra on a
4 mois de précampagne
chacun propose ses leaders son approche
ces projets des idées parce que c'est
bien parler de temps en temps des
projets et des idées avant de parler
uniquement tactique ou stratégie
électorale regardons d'abord ce qu'on
proposant chaque région
regardons s'il est candidat les projets
sont compatibles si les approches sont
compatibles moi je vous dis que en
ile-de-france la personnalité de ben ali
khreiss est une personnalité que je
trouve compatibles il ya des cas
absolument pas de compatir vous savez
quand françois bayou parler de la région
par exemple rhône alpes il ya eu des
déclarations par exemple du chef de file
ump lajournade qui sont va dire très à
droite
les dernières déclarations quant à
taubira est ce qui s'est passé sur ce
drame atroce en france ce sont des
déclarations dans lesquelles on se
retrouve pas forcément mais par ailleurs
nous verrons comment tout cela ira mais
notre responsabilité à nous responsables
du centre c'est au fond de représenter
cette sensibilité du centre et ses
électeurs du centre dans les mois qui
viennent vous entends bien j'ai après
nous verrons comment nous ferons région
par rej vous entends bien pour les
régionales ne vous êtes en train de dire
finalement ce qui est important c'est de
représenter notre sensibilité du centre
va ça correspond exactement au principe
de primaires ouvertes à la droite et au
centre est ce que ça serait une
compatibilité potentiel avant la
primaire ouverte soyons clairs regardez
c'est d'abord la primaire de l'ump quand
vous regardez quand vous voyez l'idée
même telles qu'elles se font vos
camarades du centre de l'espace hama
pour ce qu'avait dit on va dire que
c'est plutôt la primaire de l'ump elle
interviendra dans 18 mois
vous savez très bien quelle est notre
position plus que nous soutenons avec
françois bayrou nous soutenons la
possibilité si jamais alain juppé sort
on va dire vainqueur de cette primaire
françois bayrou a dit je suis prêt à le
soutenir ce qui n'est pas rien vous
savez c
en politique c'est pas la question n'est
pas si vous avez un candidat à la
primaire moi c'est ma réponse je ne vais
pas avoir un candidat à la primaire et
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous c'est
françois bayrou et vous vous en pensez
quoi
ça serait bien ce serait bien pour
porter votre mouvement moi je te les
hideuses rennes très très bien qu'alain
juppé gagner cette primaire c'est un
candidat qui serait compatible et qui
permettrait je crois des rassemblements
larges dont le pays a besoin et s'il
perd à ce moment là ça veut dire que
vous avez un candidat n'en sera pas le
safptr nous mais je vais vous répondre
s'il perd françois bayrou a dit très
clairement vous seront libres voilà nous
verrons nous serons libres ou verrait
très bien
on reste aux futurs merci merci à vous
on reste avec nous à suivre la météo et
le grand décryptage en va revenir ce
soir sur les affaires de pédophilie